uh welcome back i think we're starting
it's really hard to tell because i don't
see people trickling into the room
but hey right
here we go so hi i am alan
and this is the second part of the
online learning abandon tutorial
thanks for out there for the uh really
informative first part
and while welcome talked about online
learning i'm going to talk about bandits
so uh the first question is
um why is my zoom okay here we go what
is a bandit
well a bandit is kind of it's a
similar language for from full
information
where it's it's a way to describe
interacting with the world through
basically playing a game with some
adversary um maybe a sarcastic or maybe
it's adversarial but we're
really modeling um one while the world
is something that we can play a
sequential game with a repeated game
with
however in full information we got to
see the losses of all the actions we
could have taken
and in bandits we cannot that's
essentially the big difference
so here's the typical banded protocol
and yes these were color coordinated
with vouchers so hopefully they should
be familiar
so the typical bandit finite arm
vertical
is that you're given some game length
and a number of arms
okay and for each of capital t
rounds the learner picks some
arm and then the adversary
simultaneously picks some reward
that maps all possible armpits to the
unit interval for simplicity we'll just
assume everything's found in zero one
and then the learner observes the reward
that they
uh chose and then they see the reward
that they
chose and the key difference here is
that the learner does not observe the
rewards that they didn't choose so
uh unlike for information where you know
you can go back and evaluate how well
other
actions would have done in the past you
can't do that explicitly in depth
and that's i guess the key uh
tension that this uh this formula
brings up and just like in full
information we're going to try to
control the regret
and in this case the regrets are random
variable and is
just defined as the best action in
hindsight
minus the regret that we actually
obtained right so this
from the left is the best that you could
have gotten had you
known what would have been the best arm
and the term on the right is just the
reward that you actually ended up
getting
and
unlike for information this is actually
a random variable
so we'll have to maybe take an
expectation or something
but for now what does uh
bandits have to do with our well we can
think of a bandit as a really really
simple mdp
where you have one state and you always
transition from one state
so you're just playing an action seeing
that reward and then you're staying in
this state
so that kind of maybe is a little too
simplistic but actually
the bandit strategy has enough structure
to
be able to teach you something these are
something that we could you know
hopefully apply to rf
so as i kind of mentioned before there's
this tension between
exploration and exploitation probably
heard about this exploration
exploitation trap before
but the main idea is you every round
have to try to do two competing
things one is explore you want to find
out what arms are good
um and the only way you can do them is
by playing them so that means sometimes
you'll have to play some up
small actions um purposefully or actions
you think might be suboptimal but maybe
they won't end up being and the other
thing you might want to try to do is
exploit which is to play actions that
have done well before
and you're always trying to balance
these two
these two competing goals right and
uh exploration and exploitation is
mostly absolutely full of information
but in rl it's a pretty important
problem
so for i guess the hope is that some of
the algorithms some of the insights we
have from the banning case we can sort
of report
some of the techniques will be
applicable to rl and we'll see a little
bit of that tomorrow
and unlike rl uh the band algorithm is
pretty simple and it's simple enough to
allow for really
comprehensive theory for some of these
very easy
problem businesses by comprehensive i
mean we have
uh upper and lower bounds that match up
to constants
and we really can understand how hard
learning is in some of these
some of these games uh additionally we
can
easily incorporate adversarial data i
didn't really specify anything but how
the rewards are generated
uh and all what we really
kind of assume is that uh
i guess the adversary can see our
current strategy at the
current round but maybe not the exact
realization of say the
the strategy that we're taking so we'll
have to be forced to play
well we must play randomly and adversary
you can see what random strategy we're
using but not actually the
loss of the actual actual action that we
sampled because if the adversary could
see that then they would
just give all the reward to all the arms
that we aren't playing
right so the other orange would be good
and we would have a high
high reward in the comparator and then
our reward would be very small
so you must play randomly and
this bandit setting has a couple of
algorithmic design principles and i
think
now i'm planning to align the talk
around
presenting three or four that could be
useful and that have been useful in the
rl setting
okay so let's think about the regret for
a second and
i kind of copied it at the top again and
here the regret is a random variable
that we don't really observe right it's
the best action in hindsight minus
the actual rollout that we got so
we don't observe what rt of a is right
we can't actually evaluate what this
left
hand term is but of course we can try to
take a
with at least our randomness so the
easiest thing we can possibly hope to
control is called the suit of regret
the suit of regret is the maximum over
kind of the expected
and here the expectation is with respect
to the the
randomization of the learner and it's
the difference between the
expected regret of the best action
versus the expectation over our own
plays
slightly harder than that sometimes is
the expected regret
which is just literally the expectation
of their grip and the difference here
is that this comparator term a might
depend on the
actions that we actually played in the
past um you can show that
if uh the adversary is kind of simple
these two
are equal but generally they expect
expected regrets and upper bound
we can also ask for high high
probability bonds on the realized regret
so actually
trying to find a bound on r of t the
random variable that holds the height
probability
and these are all things that people try
to do but for this talk we'll pretty
much stick with suit of regret because
it's the easiest and there are some
pretty precise results for it
i also i guess i mentioned that the
pseudoregular is always upper bounded by
expected regret
and uh we might consider different types
of adversaries so
in valor's case you have this super a
super difficult adversary that could
actually even see your play this round
um this that's maybe a little too hard
but we
can consider uh what we call reactive
adversaries meaning that the
distribution of the
uh the regret the reward function we see
this round could depend on our
actual actions in the past um sometimes
it makes a lot of sense
to consider oblivious adversary so
oblivious adversary basically chooses
all the rewards or at least
distributions or
rewards before the game actually starts
so
this is uh a pretty natural case when
you're dealing with id data because in
that case the rewards just sampled from
some probability distribution
and there isn't any adaptiveness to your
plays going on here
and in the case of oblivious adversaries
the pseudo regret is equal to the
expected regret so that kind of helps
justify
dealing with pseudo-regret as a as a
proxy for the the real regret
okay so this talk we're going to focus
on some popular bandit problems
um i'll introduce the adversarial bandit
problem the stochastic banner problem
and also the pure acceleration bandit
problem with an idea that these are
useful
primitives for rl a given time we'll
talk briefly about contextual bandits
and for these problems we'll solve them
using a variety of algorithm techniques
and i'll try to present the
proofs of simple versions of these
algorithms in as much detail as they can
and the design principles we'll
concentrate on are exponential weights
which we've seen quite a bit in voucher
stock
optimism or also known as optimism in
the face of uncertainty
and probability matching which is more
often known as thomson sampling
and for the pure exploration balance
we'll talk about action elimination
so each of these design principles kind
of give rise to algorithms that solve
these specific bandit problems
and often they give rise to very uh
clean analysis as well okay
so that's what we're going to look at
but i really want to highlight with the
slide that there's a lot of different
ways we could expand on the banded
problem there's a lot of different band
problems that have been considered right
you might think of different data models
for the rewards
uh we will we'll look at adversary and
iid but there's other
intermediate models as well you might
look at different action spaces
so in this talk we're pretty much going
to focus on a finite number of arms but
just like you saw in router stock they
could be uh some functional optimization
over a real vector split space in which
case you're doing you know online band
optimization
they can be combinatorial that's pretty
interesting when you're trying to pick
say paths on a graph and you only
observe the uh
links of the correspond to the path like
the weights of the links that you picked
or maybe you only get to see the uh
total length
of the path that you took there are
different objectives right pseudo regret
the actual realized regret and i guess
you can think of best or magnification
as a different objective called simple
regret there's a connection here but
that's one more way you could uh push
push the bandit theory
and there is in the presence of side
information right
uh also known as contextual bandits and
this is not a comprehensive slide but
there's a lot of different ways and a
lot of different directions that people
have looked at for the bandit problem
so we're just going to look at the most
basic ones okay
so let's start with adversarial bandits
so with adversarial bandits
let me just restrain the protocol so for
the adversarial bandit only
we've suddenly become pessimistic so we
can uh
kind of play better with our full
information brothers and
this is uh stated in terms of losses
usually for bandits you save things in
terms of rewards but for the proofs for
every several bandits it's just easier
to do things and losses even though
they're kind of
uh you can convert between the two so
for this adversarial banner problem
we're given a game length t
and the number of arms k and then for
each little t
from one to t the learner will pick some
action in this set
and the adversary will simultaneously
pick some loss
that maps every single action to zero
one and then the learner will observe
the loss that they saw and receive that
loss
and of course they don't see the losses
of any other any of the other arms
so as i mentioned a few slides ago
randomization of id
is essential that you can very easily
show that any deterministic
algorithm from the learner can be made
to take linear regret which is to say
get a constant
amount of loss every round which is
pretty bad because you're not really
learning in that case
and if you look at this algorithm you
might think well this
is pretty similar to the experts setting
maybe we could just think of uh
trying to estimate what lt
is from the feedback that we actually
get that's the first
idea you might try and indeed that's
actually called the exp3 algorithm which
stands for
exponential waste for exploitation
exploration exploitation i believe
and that is exactly the idea
of running exponential weights on an
estimate of the loss
so here is the algorithm itself and
here i i've used p's instead of the w's
that voucher did i mean w's appear but
basically you at every round from
rounds uh t equals one to t you sample
your action
and then you observe the loss and then
oh if i click click on the next slide no
it will not
great then you estimate the entire loss
vector or the loss at all the actions
from
this what's known as an importance
weighted estimate right so this
is basically says that this estimates
the loss as being zero
at every single point except for the arm
that you actually picked
in which case it gets amplified by one
over p t i t
so if you say have a action you think is
not very suboptimal and you don't put a
lot of
a lot of weight on it then the times
that you do take that action you want to
account for the fact that you're really
expecting to not play the action very
often so you need to boost up its
its weight that's kind of the idea and
this lt hat is just the cumulative
loss estimates and as you see for
exponential weights all it does
is it plays arm i proportional to e to
the minus
eta times the cumulative loss but in
this case it's the estimated cumulative
loss
and wt is your uh partition function or
what you need to get these probabilities
to actually sum to one
okay so uh yeah i got it right that's
what exp3 stands for
and l hat is the important important way
to estimate and you can check
really easily and this is a standard
trick that you see all throughout rl and
machine learning that l hat is l hat t
is unbiased
indeed if you just write out what this
is you take the expectation with respect
to the actual
uh random player that you make i t and
you write out what the form of
l hat of t i is here i is just the i
coordinate
well um when you write that out that's
just equal to
by definition l of t at i t divided by p
t of i t
times the indicator that i t is equal to
i right if you write out what this
expectation is
is equal to this sum and then you'll
notice that the pts
cancel and the only uh this this
indicator will
kill off all the terms in the sum except
for the one corresponding with j is
equal to one
so this whole expression is just equal
to l of t at i sorry i said j equals the
one that j equals the i
so this whole expression is just equal
to lt at i which is
exactly what this estimate was trying to
estimate and that's it
so the analysis is pretty similar
i actually won't go into the details
though once these slots are posted
they're
included at the back if you really are
curious
but we're going to assume that you
basically did the same sort of
telescoping argument this log some x
argument that doubter used in the
exponential weights case
and uh ooh i have a question
um i'll answer this question later sorry
aaron
um maybe on the next slide so the uh
the telescoping argument is
you do exactly the same thing and once
you do some rearrangement you'll get
a term that looks really similar to what
uh vallejo had you have
the sort of expected regret so
in the full information case this left
hand side was just the actual
difference in losses here we have to
take an expectation
and the right hand said we still have
this log k over eta plus
eta times something that's sort of
linear and i believe this
was the actual value of the losses but
instead we have
basically this variance like term where
we have to account for the fact that
um lt hat is random
fortunately we can
bound uh down the terms and
compute the left-hand side really easily
so the left-hand side
is just uh an application that
or we just use the fact that it's uh
unbiased right so the expectation of
l-hat
and the exposition of big l hat are just
equal to the right values
so this is just equal to the sum of
p t of j lt of j which
is as you can see the pseudo regret or
if we pick
i star to be the actual best it would be
the suit of regret
so since this analysis
basically was for an arbitrary i star it
holds for the best i star so this
is a lower bound on uh rt actually an
upper bound rt sorry
that's a typo um and
the other thing we have to do is to
bound this variance term and
uh the variance term is
fortunately surprisingly easy to get a
control to get control over and we can
just do this by track
by direct calculation so if you plug in
what the actual
form of lp hat is you see that you
get the expectation and this expectation
is with respect to this random i t that
you chose
it's expectation of the sum over j of p
j of
l t squared over p t i t
big i t squared times the indicator
function
well that we can upper bound by saying
the losses are bounded so this lt
squared is just upper bounded by one
squared and this is this expression and
then we notice that the sum
has again uh this
this property that this will drop out
for all i t not equal to i so we're left
with the expectation of one over
p t i t and when we evaluate this this
is equal to k because
this is just the sum from i equals one
to k
of p t i divided by p t i
okay so once we can we plug those in
this is the final
exponential weights analysis like bound
that we have and as usual we have to go
and then figure out what the right eta
is so with the right eta
we get that the pseudo regret of ucb is
upper bounded by square root of two tk
log k
and we'll i can see that this is off by
a factor of k
and that's compare with full regret this
is off by a factor of k there's extra k
in here
and that's the price for partial
information this is the price for having
to explore
multiple actions and therefore take some
optimal regret
on those rounds
okay so
um oh someone answer the question thank
you
uh and as
we have done the last one in this talk
it will also point out lower bounds when
they're relevant because
they have a comprehensive theory and
that sometimes gives us lower bounds
so a lower bound on the adversarial
banner problem is
that the sugar regret has to be at least
square root of tk
that's pretty good because that exp3
algorithm we saw
had only a log k factor off
so already this you know pretty simple
shove in the importance weighted
estimates into ex
into exponential weights does pretty
well and
uh it's known how to shave off this
extra law k there's a couple algorithms
that do that the first one
was the implicit normalized normalized
forecaster
by odu there in blue in 2009 and that's
basically mirror descent
okay so what upgrades can we have on
this scenario
well the first thing you might ask is
alan you told me about
pseudoregret what about high probability
balance well you can indeed get high
probability bounds but not with this
algorithm
the problem with with exp3 is that these
importance weights have way too much
variance to be able to control so
getting high probability balance is
impossible so you have to do something
more clever so one
option is to add a little regularization
parameter to this lp hat
and then to also control the probability
distribution by mixing it a little bit
with the uniform
and that has the uh effect of keeping
these pts bounded away from zero so you
can actually get an upper bound on this
lp hat
uh another more elegant solution is by
gergei who's sitting around here
somewhere
oh hey gary then uh that's using
explicit input
or explicit exploration where you have
this little gamma t at the bottom
so this basically has the same effect of
keeping the probabilities well bounded
and you can push through these analyses
and get high probability bounds
there are other ways you can generalize
this you can look at you can mix bandits
and experts so
instead of each arm being a single
action you can think of each arm being
an expert and experts will then
recommend different actions you can take
and then your uh your choice is which
expert do you follow and which action do
you then pick
and that was solved by the exp4
algorithm which is actually pretty
similar to the xb3 algorithm in the same
paper
you can compete with strategies that can
switch
and much like in the full information
case you can assume that your
competitors are allowed certain number
of switches
you can have feedback that isn't just of
the action that you pick but that's
determined by some graph so all your
actions are embedded on a graph and when
you play an action you get to see the
loss of all the neighbors as well
that's one generalization that makes the
game easier another generalization that
makes the game harder is partial
monitoring
where you don't even get to see the loss
of the action that you picked instead
you have some sort of
feedback uh some signaling graph that
you get to observe
um but there's a lot of different
upgrades and extensions of this
um of these sort of algorithms of this
problem setting actually
okay so that was adversarial bandits so
let's look at stochastic bandits which
is the next big thing
and so kasich bandits as you can kind of
guess is just adversarial bandits
when the arms are stochastic
really so in in this case you have a
reward distribution
a new one through new k over each arm
and during arm i
you pick arm big i t and then you get to
see a sample from the distribution
and your goal is basically to find the
arm with the highest mean
and this is the namesake of the bandit
problem because you can imagine
that each arm corresponds with the slot
machine and you pull an arm and you get
that reward and you're trying to find
the slot machine with the highest mean
i mean obviously so sarcastic bandits is
a really old problem
it's from at least thompson 1933 and the
notation
is that we will use is that the reward
of arm i
is i guess sampled from nu i and the
mean will be mu y
we're going to let the best arm be i
star
and we will define whoops these gaps
which is the
the gap of arm i which is the difference
between the best mean you can get and
the mean if you play arm i
and we'll also need to denote the number
of pools and
i n sub i t which is the number of poles
of arm
i up and up through the first
t uh pools of the algorithm and then the
empirical mean
mu hat of i t is uh the empirical mean
of arm i on all the all the samples you
got from arm i
up until time t okay
so the regret the notion of regret
expect regret
is uh very has a very nice decomposition
in this case
and as i mentioned on slide two for uh
for oblivious adversaries the expected
regret and to regret
are equal so when the adversaries are
not even adversaries when they're just
stochastic
that means that the suit of regret and
the expected regret are equal so we'll
unabashedly just talk about expected
regret in this case
well what's the expected regret well
it's the best is the regret or the best
thing you could have gotten which is
just
t times mu i if you knew what the best
arm is you would only play that
minus the expectation of the arms of the
samples you actually played
and this is kind of a regret that works
by
per arm or works over rounds but you
might think of how the regret decomposes
per
um per arm so basically every time you
play
a sub-optimal arm you incur an
expectation
that delta i so the regret is also equal
to the sum over arm's i
of delta i times expected number of
times you would have pulled that arm
at the end of the game which is nit and
this is usually the form
we will use so for all the analysis
we'll see we will bound
expectation of n i comma t and then
add them together with a delta in front
okay and
we'll need some sort of assumption on
the tail of the
uh of the reward distributions one
simple assumption
is that they're bounded but it's not
that hard to generalize to some gaussian
reward distribution so
just to refresh everyone's memory we'll
say that a random variable is one
subgaussian if
effectively it had gaussian tails so
that means this sort of turn off style
inequality is
zero but you might think conceptually of
the random variable as having tails that
drop off slower than the unit gaussian
importantly if the very random variable
is one sub gaussian then we have this
tufting bound
which just says that the probability
that the empirical mean
cro concentrates around the true mean
and the probability that
the empirical mean is more than epsilon
greater than the true mean
drops off really quickly it drops off
the e to the minus epsilon squared t
over two
okay and we'll use this over and over
again but this is a very standard result
so let's think about this this thread
this
problem right what's the first algorithm
you might try well it might be
explorer then commit and explore within
commit is pretty
aptly named and that you explore all the
arms
and then you commit to the best one and
you pull it to the end of the game
so explorer on the commit really has one
parameter m and
for the first m times k rounds it just
chooses
that arm it chooses uh a round robin arm
and i guess t mod k and then it computes
all the empirical means and then it
follows
the best arm well in that case the
regret
is very easy to calculate right we'll
calculate the regret by
bounding this expectation over nt and
well what's nt
expectation over nt is equal to m
because you definitely pull
every arm n times plus e
is equal to t minus mk times the
probability that you selected that arm
i right so remember after mk rounds you
try to find what the best arm is
and then you fold that for the rest of
the game so if that happens you will
incur another t
minus mk pools of that arm and if it
doesn't then you'll include another zero
poles on that arm okay so we want to
bound uh
bound that quantity and boundaries
quantity actually turns out to be
pretty straightforward so when do you
choose arm i to follow will you choose
arm i when the empirical mean of i
is greater than the empirical mean of i
star right
and we can then just add the gaps back
in so if we add a
uh a mu i sorry a delta i to this side
and then
add a delta i star minus delta i to this
side and rearrange what we'll see is
we're just left with two
well we're left with the zero mean
random variable here and zero i mean
random variable here
so this whole probability is a question
about the difference of
two means of or the difference of the
means of two zero mean
once i've got some random variables
being greater than delta i
so that is also a question of a single
square root two over m sub gas and
random variable being greater than delta
i and if we use hupton's bound this is
just how big it is it's
smaller than e to the minus m delta i
squared over 4.
then we take that and we shove it back
into our algorithm and we show that
the expected regret is upper bounded by
the sum over i
of that should be a one of delta i times
the number of times we pulled arm i
or the expected number of times we've
pulled rmi which is m
plus t minus mk e to the minus m delta
squared over four
uh which is sort of an awkward thing and
the first
impulse you probably have is to try to
tune m
to make this have like a a t in it
be a more simple function of t and that
turns out to be kind of hard but in the
two arm case
you can see that if you know delta then
you can set m to be
roughly one over delta squared times log
t of delta
and the total bound unexpected right you
get is order
k log t over delta the problem with this
is that you have to know what delta is
and that's not really a reasonable
assumption
so can we be adaptive and
that sort of brings us to our second
algorithm design principle the first
being exponential weights and the second
that we'll talk about today is
ofu or optimism in the face of
uncertainty and the
main idea is as follows you establish
some confidence set on where you think
the true parameters could be
then you take the most favorable
plausible set of parameters and then you
play greedily
that's that's why it's optimism in the
phase of uncertainty because you're
being optimistic so here's what this
algorithm looks like it's the famous
ucb1 algorithm
and it works as follows so
first it just plays every round once
then on subsequent rounds it computes
this
upper confidence bound so b i
of t minus 1 is equal to square root of
6 log t over the number of times you
pull arm i
and this has a a huffy amount like
flavor to it and that's exactly why you
need to have something of this form
and then you choose the arm that
maximizes the upper confidence bound
that maximizes the empirical mean of arm
i
plus this bound of rmi then once you
choose that you observe a sound from
this distribution and then you update
right so let's think about this uh with
an illustration
so here this is i guess maybe around
four because we've pulled all arms one
time but we have
three arms and we can kind of guess that
arm one is better than arm two is better
than arm three but we're not entirely
certain
but these are plotting uh the empirical
means and also the upper
and lower confidence bounds so really we
only need the upper ones so in arm one
we have these confidence bounds for the
means and we're going to be optimistic
we're going to say i'm going to assume
that the true mean of r1 is at the very
top of this
interval the true meaning of arm two is
the top of this interval and the true
mean of arm three is at the top of this
interval
in that case what's the great thing to
do also play arm one so that's what we
do we play arm one
um then we see that we got more
information so the confidence interval
on this arm
shrinks a bit and now what are we going
to do well we're going to do the same
sort of
counter factual and in this case the
true mean of arm 2
is plausibly better than the true mean
of all the other arms so we pick arm 2.
and we see the arm 2 kind of decreases
and on the third round then we'll want
to pick arm 3 because now this ucb is
bigger
and we've kind of seen that this
algorithm naturally balances exploration
exploitation
because if it picks an arm then it's
likely that either that arm has a really
high empirical mean
or that r hasn't seen that many samples
so
the uh so the um
i'm sorry it's got a notification so the
uncertainty is really large
okay uh what does the analysis look like
it's
actually not super bad to at least bound
analysis for the simple case
and the key insight here is to think to
define
m i to be equal to 12. some constant
times
log big t over delta i squared what is m
i well m i
is about the number of times we'd expect
to pull arm i
before we eliminate our arm i as being
the best
right we need to pull arm i roughly one
over
delta i big delta i squared times to be
able to
uh narrow it down to a region of size
delta i and that log t there is because
we're
using union bound over time so that's
kind of why we have to set
the upper bounds to be the size that
they are namely if we choose
b of i t given what the algorithm
specifies that means that
b of i t is less than or equal to delta
delta i over t once we've seen at least
mi samples
so the intuition of the proof is pretty
much the same
as the one from exploring commit so we
try to bound the expected number of
pools of all the suboptimal arms
all right and that's just equal to the
uh the sum
over all the events that we pull arm i
at round t
and that is upper bounded by m i plus
the probability that we will pull arm i
in the future
right so the number of times we'll pull
arm
i after we've pulled it mi times already
and the idea
is that we will with very small
probability not pull an arm
more than mi times which means that the
total regret will be
about the sum of delta i times mi
which is what it turns out being so
on the next slide we kind of just bound
this probability
so we can do this in a picture so
why not uh the claim is that if
we are so we want to bound the
probability of choosing arm i
and what we really have are these
notions of upper confidence bound so we
kind of want to argue that if the upper
upper confidence bounds are correct then
we won't make this mistake
and then we'll argue that the upper
confidence balance are almost always
correct
so if we make this mistake and we
actually choose arm i
after mi that means
that well first we know that mu
so condition on the events that the
upper confidence bounds are correct
then we know that mu hat i plus sorry mu
hat i star plus
b i star is greater than u i and we know
that
mu i star and we know that mu i star is
more than
2 b times mu i because that's how we
chose m
we chose m such that d would be smaller
than delta i over 2. well
how far can mu hat plus
bib from mu well it could be one
size of bi from just having the mean be
a noisy estimate
and then we add another b on it but
still once we've added
both of these in the most pessimistic
way possible we see that we really still
can't get it so that
mu hat i dt is bigger than the upper
confidence bound of the best arm
so if that actually happens if we
actually pick
arm i that means that one or both of
these confidence intervals must be false
so that's this inequality right if we
pick this arm then either this
the mu uh hat icons interval is
incorrect or the mu hat i start
confidence interval is incorrect
and we can bound uh both of those just
using simple algebra
right we unfortunately this b has an n i
t which is a random variable so we can
just take a
union bound over it we add them up we
shove in
this expression into our hufting bound
and we just get out
and we do some algebra and equality to
the minus two and the similar thing
holds for the mu hat i star case so
when we do that like i promised earlier
we
bounded this expectation we shoved it
back into our decomposition and we get
that the regret is upper bounded by the
sum over
arms of the gap of arm i plus
2 log t over delta i squared plus
lower order stuff we don't care about
okay
so uh that's this theorem and
of course the question is how good can
we do and
the answer is actually rather famous is
the lion robbins lower bound from 1985
and it basically shows that um for any
admissible algorithm so basically an
algorithm that
does well on most problems on all
problem instances
the pseudo regret divided by log t has
to grow at least
um equal whoops at least as quickly as
uh log t and the constant has to be
delta i over the kl
of uh the difference between arm i and
arm i star
and for like the bernoulli case for
example
the kl divergence is of order
delta i squared so this whole thing is
of order one over delta i
so we're kind of like a log t off of
this lower bound
i'm sorry yeah we're um getting like
within constants for this lower bound
because log t is on the left so that's
pretty good
um okay so that was how well optimism
did and there's still room for
improvement but you know we kind of feel
that we've got at least a good portion
of the way there and the
algorithm design principle that really
helped us was uncertainty
which isn't the only algorithm design
principle we could have used in fact
we're going to use
uh probability matching instead so for
probability matching which is a totally
different way of solving the same
problem we're going to put a prior over
means and then look at a likelihood
right so we'll have priors over mean i
and a likelihood new i which gives us a
sample given
mu i and what we want to do is we want
to pull arm
i equal to the probability that rmi is
actually the best that's the matching
part
and you might know this algorithm by its
other names called usually thomson
sampling
and thompson's sampling works exactly
that way
so you can implement this probability of
choosing
arm i proportional to the probability of
the arm is the best by instead
drawing some sample from his from his
posterior
and then picking the sample that's the
highest so this is just a
different way of sampling according to
this probability
so um that's what we do then once we
have the arm of course we
we observe the reward and we update the
posterior of the arm that we pulled
okay so here's kind of an idea of what
this sort of looks like and the first
thing you might
wonder is well is this bayesian no not
really a
bayesian would put a prior like we did
over the problem instances but then
would
solve the problem under that prior and
would prove something of the bayes
optimal regret they expect to regret
underneath
once you like integrate out all the
prior parameters instead we're
only using this posterior as a algorithm
tool
so we're not at we're not really
integrating with respect to the predator
we're getting
a freaking just bound which is to say an
instant
dependent performance bound uh
so why is this a sensible thing to do
well if you kind of think of this photo
or this this cartoon if mu hat
i is high then we'll tend to pick
arm i right remember the sampling
procedure is to generate a posterior
sample from this distribution
generate a posterior sample from this
distribution and then see which one's
higher and choose that one
so if new mu i tends to be high we'll
tend to select it more often
um also if mu if we haven't seen mu
very often and it has a really large
spread like mu uh whoops it should be
this is mu
one like b one has here then there'll be
some non-trivial chance that we'll play
it so we'll do some exploration as well
um the reason why people really like
thompson sampling is it is
more aggressive than ucb and tends to do
better in practice
um the downside is that the analysis is
much more difficult because you don't
have this upper confidence property to
sort of exploit
and uh the first analysis
of this algorithm was um argo and goyle
in 2013 and they showed that the regret
of the
beta gamma beta thomson sampler where
you just have
um gamma priors or beta priors and the
gamma likelihood
is exactly equal to what you would hope
it would be
it's uh you know sum over t of delta i t
times log t over the kl which is sort of
the optimal order like
you might hope and then i mentioned the
uh
proof is a lot more technical so i'm
just going to very
vaguely talk about how the proof sort of
works
and the idea again is to break down the
expected
regret into the expected number of some
optimal plays and the
expectation can be broken down to these
three oops into these three cases
so here we're going to think about um mu
1 is the optimal arm and mu 2 is a sub
optimal arm we're going to think about
two
points between which we'll have to two
and you get the analysis to work out
and if we're choosing arm two
in this case well um arm two can happen
for a couple of in a couple of different
circumstances one
is if the mean of arm two is well
behaved so that means this is less than
x t's was close to the true mean
but the posterior sample of arm two
happens to be really big
right and that we can control because
once the mean concentrates the posterior
tends to concentrate
um another thing that could happen is
the mu
arm is small and the posterior sample
isn't that
large so both are kind of well behaved
and in this case you're
generally picking arm the sub optimal
arm when you got a really bad sample
from really bad posterior tempo from the
optimal arm
so this sort of happens when you don't
have enough samples from the optimal arm
we have to show that doesn't happen that
often and then the last case that might
happen is if
uh the mean of arm i is just like crazy
and you didn't learn it that well and
that doesn't happen
just through concentration right we know
that the mean mu had i concentrates
around the true mean
so this is the tricky case and they
basically
rely on this lemma that shows that the
probability
of picking arm i given that rmi has
reasonable mean rewards and meet
a reasonable posterior sample is bounded
by some constant
uh times the probability of picking the
best arm
which means that this problem of not
having picked the best arm
goes away exponentially quickly and in
fact this whole contribution to the
regret is order one
so i know that was super high level um
but you can go over the proof it's
actually pretty digestible you just
can't
fit it into a tutorial
okay so a quick aside
you might have said well we have
stochastic algorithms and adversarial
algorithms and they're really different
can we somehow get the best of both
worlds um
we know that the regret for adversarial
has to be square root
k and then the regret for stochastic has
to be logarithmic
um so you know what's can we
adapt without knowing the setting and
people have tried this so one of the
first examples was
uh an algorithm proposed to boo the food
back in slivkins and they
assumed an id problem and then did
basically a
hypothesis test to determine whether
they fall into an adversarial
regime or not and once they do then
they'll switch to every single algorithm
um but recently this problem was
answered um
more precisely at least in the case of
pseudoregret
with a variant of the online mirror
descent so this algorithm which is on
the mirror descent with a sort of
weird half salice entropy which is a
salis entropy corresponding with alpha
equals a half which i've written down
here but it's
not clear at all why it's special from
the way it's written
is able to simultaneously get
the optimal regret optimal uh
pseudoregret bounds in both cases
without knowing which one is which
and uh this is not possible for
not suitable regret and it's certainly
not possible on best arms but for
pseudoregret you can totally do this
which is really surprising and
um it's definitely worth digging into
what this algorithm is actually doing
and why
have salas entropy is a really good idea
okay so here's one more different
problem we could think about which is
called pure exploration
so so far everything we've done
has been has been on
regret minimizing regret so we're
playing this repeated game and we care
about how much we're wasting as we're
playing but that's not always the case
maybe we really really just want to find
out what the best arm is and we don't
care about how many samples we have to
spend to figure that out
we're doing some exploratory research or
doing clinical trials
or something like that and it's easy to
motivate these sort of problems
so in that case what should your
algorithms look like
right we kind of want to explore more so
in the cumulative regret case
you tend not to pull arms you think are
suboptimal but
in pure exploration you kind of want to
really make sure you're getting the
optimal algorithm
and the optimal arm so this
problem is known as best r magnification
or pure exploration
and the protocol is as such so given
uh k arms and arm distributions new ones
in uk
every round you pick an arm you observe
a sample from the arm and you decide
whether you want to stop on a
stop or not at the end you have to
return an arm and there's two things you
might hope to do
one is you might hope to have fixed
confidence so that means that you
keep on selecting samples and it's up
for the learner to decide
when to stop and they want to guarantee
that they found the right arm with high
confidence
and the other is fixed budget where you
have a fixed budget and you want to
maximize the probability of getting the
right arm
under this budget constraint and uh
we'll only consider fixed confidence but
fixed budget is a thing that people
get okay so generally
as i've mentioned uh just a little bit
ago sarcastic
regret minimization bandits under
explore
we can sometimes fix them to do the
right thing so two sort of examples of
this are
l ucb which pulls not only the arm with
the highest
upper confidence bound but the arm with
the uh
lowest lower confidence bound that's
higher than the lower confidence bound
or
desire the more confidence bound on the
best arm we can also adapt thompson
sampling
which does tops up too so instead of
sampling the uh taking a sample of all
the posteriors and then taking the arm
that corresponds with the highest sample
you instead keep on resampling until you
get a different
arm and then you use that one instead
and that
encourages thompson assembly to explore
more and kind of does the right thing
um but like i said i want to introduce
more algorithm design principles so why
not pass up an opportunity to do that so
here's another algorithm design
principle action elimination and a lot
of these best form algorithm
uh algorithms best arm identification
algorithms
are using action elimination to design
their algorithms
so this is one of the earliest and um
was on the simple side but it
actually gets with the lock of the lower
bound it's called successive elimination
and the basic idea is that you keep a
list of plausibly best algorithms
and you every
round you pull all the algorithms still
in your list and then you
see which ones aren't plausibly best
anymore and you throw them away
so in this case you're comparing the
maximum
um empirical mean in your plausible set
minus some of confidence bound with the
all the other means plus the confidence
bound so this is
uh intuitively the lowest that mu star
could be
and this is the highest that mu i could
be and then
if the lowest me start could be still
higher than the highest miui could be
then you're pretty confident that mui is
not the optimal arm and you throw it out
and you keep on entering this procedure
until you're left with a set of size
one and you return that so
the nice thing about action elimination
algorithms is
they tend to have pretty straightforward
analysis at least
this one does in fact it fits all in one
page the proof so let's just go through
it because maybe it's a useful exercise
the main idea is you define this bad
event
and the bad event is the event that one
of the confidence intervals doesn't hold
um you know that this happens with small
probability in fact you can calculate
this so what's the probability
of one of the confidence intervals not
holding well we use the union bound so
it's the sum
over all i t of the probability that the
confidence interval didn't hold for that
arm i at that time t
and given that this is the ucb that we
chose we just plug it in and we use
hupton's bound again
and we get that this union bound is the
probability of the bad event is upper
bounded by the sum over i t
of 2 times e to the minus half log k t
squared over delta
um and then we pull push through the
expectation
and we do some summing and we found this
is just less than delta so
with high probability all our confidence
bounds are correct
and of course this didn't happen by
accident we had to choose
the confidence balance so that they
would add up you can choose any sort of
confidence bounds that hold across all
time if you want but this is one that
does
okay so with high probability we're in
we don't have this bad event happening
now
we show correctness of the algorithm so
if the bad event doesn't happen we want
to show that the algorithm is correct
well
if the bad event doesn't happen that
means our confidence intervals are
always correct for all
arms in all time which means
that at time at round j
if we look at the difference between mu
hat j and mu hat i
well we can just add and subtract mu j
and ui
so this is less than or this is uh less
than
we had i minus sorry mu i star minus
mu hat i star plus the gap
plus mu hat j minus mu j
and this whole thing right this is less
than or equal to zero
this is bounded by a huffington bound or
given the huffy minus correct is less
than b
and given that the huffington bounds are
correct this is also less than b so this
whole thing is less than 2b
and if you look back at the previous
algorithm on the previous line which i
can do pretty easily you'll see
that arm mu i is eliminated
only if it is more than 2b smaller than
the best
so in that case arm i star will never be
eliminated because it is never more than
2b smaller than the best arm in this
class
so you never remove i star that that's
the goal right condition on the good
event happening
i star is never eliminated from your
plausibly best pool
then you notice that as you go
uh as the game progresses this bi will
eventually go to zero so you will
eliminate every single arm except for
one
and by induction that has to be the best
arm so
with high probability right with
probability equal to the probability of
the bad event not happening
this algorithm will terminate with the
optimal arm so that's the correctness
proof
um and the second part of the proof is
asking about
sample complexity right what is the
sample complexity how many times does it
have to pull
arms in order to stop and uh
okay i kind of fly saying that it fits
on one slide because this is sort of
hand weaving but
at a high level you need to pull arm i
enough
so that uh delta i is smaller than two
of bt and you can actually eliminate it
and you kind of compute you can invert
this bound and show
that that actually needs order delta i
uh to minus 2 times log k over delta i
squared
and then you add these up for every arm
and that's effectively the order of the
total sample complexity right it's
uh sum over i of uh one over square
the square of the gap plus log k
over delta uh big delta
and nicely on this slide uh so
of course there are lower bounds too and
the lower bound
is that every best arm identification
algorithm
um or rather for every best arm
identification algorithm there is a
problem instance that requires at least
uh delta i over log i delta i to the
minus two times log log one over
delta delta i squared samples so we're
like a log k
off and uh a log log off as well
and there are fancier algorithms that do
actually get this log log bound
and the log log down kind of has
something to do with a lot of iterative
logarithms so it shouldn't look too
weird
but um you have to be a lot more careful
about
how often you compare actions successive
elimination is sort of the the simplest
way of doing it
but it's also one of the simplest and
kind of appropriate for boot camp
yeah so that's kind of best our
magnification
and i guess we have a little bit of time
so i can maybe quickly go into linear
stochastic bandits
so this is almost a contextual balance
and it's the last thing that we'll
consider
and uh the setting is as such so
given a given number of arms k as usual
the learner now sees some context so
they see one context per context per arm
c one all the way to c k of t and
they're given nuclear context vectors
every arm
and the learner picks an action and then
they get whoops i just dropped my mouse
and that's why i want like four sides
ahead and then they get the inner
product between the contacts that they
picked
and some uh theta star they don't know
plus noise
and the regret is with respect to an
agent that knows the true
theta so if an agent is the true theta
what they would do is just
see which of these contexts is closest
to the truth theta and pick that
that's exactly what this is so in this
form of formulation
the regret of the adversary uh isn't
tying all the rounds together it's just
doing the best action every round
um so maybe this might seem harder
because you can
have a different optimal action best
every round but on the other hand
there's a lot of shared learning that
happens because if you know theta
star then you can really narrow down
what the optimal action is and you can
kind of learn theta star because it's
constant across rounds um and
the one of the earliest algorithms that
uh
solved this was this optimism in the
face of linear bandits
i think actually i don't really know
what awful stands for maybe
maybe choppa can tell us but uh
it's what's the o4 java
oh something greener oh you're muted or
i can't hear you
oh wait that just could be me
oh i think my sound is broken good thing
i can at least talk
it's optimism in the face of uncertainty
foreign
okay great so so it's that and
the idea of this algorithm is pretty
nice you basically
use optimism to try to guess what theta
is
but instead of having a optimistic
estimate for every action you have a
joint optimistic estimator by having a
confidence sequence on theta and then
choosing the best
theta right so when you play you
choose jointly i t and
theta to maximize the objective and you
are optimistic over both the actions you
have
and over the theta that's that's the
inside
so the machinery you kind of need is to
have a confidence
sequence or confidence interval on theta
they actually
used a i like to call a confidence
sequence but basically
it's a confidence interval that holds
across time and it's
out of uh the statistical literature
uses i guess method of moments and some
sort of martingale techniques
um de la pena 2009 and there's other uh
pointers i think this is actually found
a bunch of really cool
techniques so i encourage everyone to go
check them out but
the idea is you have you do linear
regression
on theta star right so i'm here i'm
defining vt to be the
covariate like the ridge regression s
version of the covariance matrix
and i'm calculating this is the ols just
the ordinary least square or i guess the
ridge
which regression estimate of what theta
is and
we're basically you can show that with
high probability
this confidence interval this confidence
sequence which is a
subset of theta and says that the truth
theta has to be
close to theta star right so with high
probability
theta star is in this set and you have
to tune with r is
so that's that's the algorithm and the
proof is super nice
uh as i mentioned the regret kind of
decomposes round by round so if you look
at the
the excess regret is a single round it's
just equal to
the uh regret of the best arm minus
the arm that you picked right and now
you can use optimism and say well since
i
chose the um i chose
the actions optimus optimistically and i
also chose a proxy for theta
optimistically i can
use this as an upper bound and just
shove this in and then once i have
whoops once i have this upper bound then
i just massage it a little bit
and i use kosher shorts and then i can
bound the grit that way so you actually
get a really strong regret guarantee in
this case
because you can learn a lot of joint
structure um
yeah so actually i somehow am pretty
much exactly on
time i think and
here's a last slide the review so what
have we looked at so far
well we looked at four different
settings of bandits and we've looked at
at least one algorithm to solve each
setting so
for the adversarial bandits we've seen
our good friend the exponential weights
come back and savor save us again
using esp3 right and so kasich bandits
we saw algorithms that really took
advantage of the stochasticity of the
data
by using uncertainty to fit the prop
model
using the usb or ucb algorithm or
we also looked at thompson sampling
which did probability matching
and had a totally different flavor but
still
got the same sort of theoretical
guarantees
in the pure exploration setting we
looked at action elimination algorithms
which had a
pretty different flavor even though the
uh tools were pretty similar
and then we very briefly looked at a
linear conduction band torque and
optimism really
seemed to be a good way of designing
algorithms
so hopefully when you have your next
sequential
uh learning or sequential decision
making problem one of these design
principles will come in handy
um i think that's all i had so if you
have any questions i'll be here for a
bit
um yes contexts in uh
in successive linear bandits are
um arbitrary that was the question the
question was can contacts in uh linear
scats events adversarial
uh yeah they can be arbitrary i mean
there are also
um adversarial versions of linear
bandits as well
though i don't know that literature so
well i see chaba because he
just had a paper on that i mean
yeah that has a big literature it's
somewhat different
uh um the whole problem set up is it's
more similar to if you have
uh a reward and you have a random noise
acting on a parameter
that corresponds to the adversarial
setting if you
generalize that array and and you
have a sequence of arbitrary of this
photometer vectors right so that
that is a sort of different setting uh
i wanted to say that the the context
whether
it is adversary or not actually if it's
not adversarial then maybe you can take
advantage of that
so it's yeah so so the result that i was
talking about
is not trying to take advantage of if
the contacts are not adversarial but if
they are not then maybe
they do better
[Music]
it's amazing that you're on time that uh
yeah i had a lot of slides i don't know
how that happened
okay um you got another question
i i asked it in the contextual setting
since context can change over time does
it mean
that we are competing against a change
optimal or
are we still competing against the best
fixed arm in hindsight
okay did you get that yeah so usually in
the contextual setting you'll
compete with some uh
classic policies or class of mappings
from context to actions
and in that case you can pay you compete
with the best policy so the policies are
fixed but you want to do as well as the
best policy in your class
so the the best action will change
so the best the best action changes
right but you would hope that at least
in the contextual band setting one of
the policies accurately captures
the uh the relationship between the
context and the actions and you'd want
to
then follow that one
okay so another question if the context
can be adversarial maybe the next
context can depend on the agent's
current action
then wouldn't this become rl
if i mean there's also the notion of
state right that your
reward at the current round is closer to
rl
it is it is like area but i think it's
just around regret
yeah right like as an aura
should we never take into account if
uh the adversary kind of like
chooses uh that their choices
are based on our action uh future
choices available in action
then we don't go back and say that like
oh if we had shoes and this other action
diversity would have done something else
that's arya right so then i'll stay
dependent regret but
here the regret is this vicious worship
concept that
that is good for reductions good for sm
mathematical tool
but otherwise it's like a strange regret
uh
some people uh so in the literature
to make a distinction between these two
regret
uh regrets uh the regret that
would everyone think about in the
context of mariah
it's called a policy regret and this
regret
is not the policy that is just the issue
yeah it's almost like a counterfactual
right
if i had run this other policy this
would have been the states that i would
have seen and this would have been the
actions i would have played
but this one is like this intermediate
thing yeah
okay
can context where any action change over
time
they can they change according to the
history of actions i think this would
answer or
that would keep us in there yeah
i guess i'll click answer live on this
we
[Music]
and uh these slides will be up i there's
a bunch of references at the back
um though if you want to learn more
about bananas you should check check out
choppa's book
they just came out there's a lot of and
tourists
sorry um and there's no i'm even the one
doing this
okay
awesome
okay i guess it's a break until uh
anka is giving a talk about robotics and
human interaction in half an hour right